you can never perfect what we do there
is no way I've never met anyone who goes
that perfection I'm not a typical beauty
so basically the long neck the long face
that's usually period that you see some
kind of inbreeding with it immediately
when he came on set it was on and like
everyone just was on their a game at all
times
hello believe nation it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in people
more than they believe in themselves and
my sincere hope is that if you see in
yourself what I see in you you'll be
able to change the planet so to help you
on your journey today we're going to
learn from actor Benedict Cumberbatch
and my take on its top ten rules it took
that rule number two is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys like the fat also as you're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down in the comments below about
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired by it as well and if you leave
it within the first couple hours of this
video going live you have a chance to
win one of two daily prizes
you can never perfect what we do there
is no way I've never met anyone who goes
that perfection I mean to an audience
outside of your work people can think
that that's the only way they'd ever
want to see that part played or that
moment done whatever but as an actor and
isn't mock humility I think it just goes
for all the art forms really the whole
point is perfection is unachievable so
it's that constant pursuit of the
unobtainable which is kind of magic
really you know and and and should keep
us kind of motivated to try better you
know it's the bakit thing no fail again
fail better there isn't a better actor
certainly for this role but perhaps
period than Benedict Cumberbatch who was
remarkable to orbit enjoy these final
moments of peace immediately when he
came on set it was on and like everyone
just was on their a-game at all times
like no one was slacking because it was
there was something about Benedict's you
know focus and and his presence that
really just helped challenge everyone to
do the best possible job is awesome at
what reason you fully commit to every
role that you play yeah so thinking when
you do fully commit to a role what are
the sacrifices you have to make to fully
commit to it up of tell apart like this
that's a very interesting question I
mean a lot I think I think specifically
when you're working you have to want a
such a good question that's such a good
question sorry so know what I mean
logistically obviously just a business
of acting the fact that you're doing
certain hours and sometimes you're
working all night and doing weird
antisocial days at weekends you forget
about your social life that that's a
sort of sacrifice to commitment that's
something quite my level at Union
sacrifices but you don't get to see your
family you don't get to see your friends
you are removed from the reality of your
life to pursue a given goal so there is
a kind of comparison
I guess you you sacrifice a part of
yourself because you're exposing either
either end of the spectrum of acting
whether it's just variations of who you
are or whether it's completely to
something into a different character in
persona you're equally valid in my
opinion I don't think there's really a
distinction to draw than people who are
good or bad at it but I think then you
do have to give as part of yourself no
matter what you're doing and that you
don't lose yourself is gain actually by
doing that but you have to suppress and
control certain instincts that you have
in order to actually be true to a
character that may not be the same as
you we driven by the same things as you
you were offered an opportunity to go to
Broadway with the play that you'd
already been a part of and made a very
it was a very difficult decision for you
but you elected not to do that because
of sort of an idea of where you want to
take things so it was very selfish
decision as well because it affected a
lot of other people I did there eight
months before we were supposed to go but
apologies to Nancy Carol and agents
Cobra and Thea Sharrock
I just wanted to mix it up all the time
I really wanted I wanted to I'm in my
theater training at lamda which was a
classical theater category English
theatre one year course and a
postgraduate course which I really
enjoyed and got a lot out of but you
know it would that was it that was the
main focus because I thought a little
bit old-fashioned in my kind of
understanding of it I thought that what
I do
what the great actors that have been
ahead of me had done and inspired me to
do was the idea of starting out in the
classics and maybe a modern play or two
than a few roles in television and then
you know getting a film role but keep
going back to theatre and that is what
I've done that is kind of what I've
tried to do the unhappy accident of that
blading-- such a huge success was it
came at a point where I thought Christ
I've actually got some momentum in a
medium where it's much more of a closed
door there's a very little long-term
memory it's much more immediate your
currencies something you really have to
kind of work on in film quite fast to a
to a degree I'm saying this in conscious
everything I say tonight is contradict
but I know that but it's just I guess
that's what a personal conversation is
really it's just a point of view but
every time I say anything I'm thinking
the opposite is also very true
that's the kind of yeah that's my head
you're getting implants it's great being
me so yeah I I really I was really lucky
to have just had a few breaks obviously
with Charlotte but also Tinker Tailor
also with Frankenstein and being cast in
warhorse and that all came to the same
kind of point where we was supposed to
be coming here to do this Broadway
production of after the dance which
might still happen might be a film we
don't know it might hit something there
might be some life left in it it was a
wonderful experience in London but I
felt that I'd had that experience there
and so officially I wanted to make some
capital out of this momentum that was
building and I I'm glad I did because I
got Star Trek and two of his labor was a
sage County and yeah where he worked out
well for me but um and then the fitted
state so I kind of them I was very yeah
I took a gamble and it paid off
I'm really glad you didn't leave college
and I really am I mean I really enjoyed
my further education I made some of my
greatest lifelong friends in those
moments and had some fantastic
experiences and we all really worked
incredibly hard on the production's we
put on so in a way it was like my
version of theater wrap which is our
steel system in England I'm sure you
know but you know is this very arduous
very difficult weekly rep system where
you'd be doing a show you'd be
rehearsing on and you'd be sort of
getting ready to stage the other I mean
three different characters and and three
different worlds and involve us and
those that there's a great stretch and
training for practice in the old days so
I schedule at moments a little bit like
that but also you know I think we will
experience that in my group at
University we put on a ridiculous amount
a sort of rhythm what drives me is
having a challenge
and meeting that challenge in a way that
will hopefully make my peers my family
and my friends proud part of it is a
thrill-seeking as well although I think
you're in a lot of danger if you just
become an adrenalin junkie but you need
stability you need stamina and you need
to be able to keep your perspective and
feel grounded and secure and what you're
doing is like why is there a man in that
torpedo there are men and women in all
those torpedoes captain I put them there
Fidel RAL a remnant of a time long past
genetically engineered to be superior so
as to lead others to peace in a world at
war
we were condemned as criminals forced
into exile for centuries we slept hoping
when they awoke things would be
different but as a result of the
destruction of Vulcan your Starfleet
began to aggressively search distant
quadrants of space my ship was found
adrift I alone was revived
I looked up John Harrison until a year
ago he'd enix long Harrison was a
fiction created the moment I was awoken
by Oh Admiral Marcus to help him advance
his cause a smokescreen to conceal my
true identity my name is Kai
why would a Starfleet Admiral ask a 300
year old frozen man proud because I am
NASA and what everything Alexander Mach
is needed to respond to an uncivilized
effect in a civilized time after that he
needed a warrior's mind my mind to
design weapons and warships you're
suggesting the Admiral violated every
regulation he vowed to uphold simply
because they wanted to exploit your
intellect wanted to exploit my savagery
intellect among diseases and fight mr.
Spock you you can't even break the rule
how would you be expected to break
Marcus used me to design weapons to help
him realize his vision of a militarized
Starfleet he sent you to use those
weapons to fire my torpedoes on an
unsuspecting planet and then he
purposely crippled your [__] in enemy
space leading to one inevitable outcome
the Klingons would come searching for
whomever was responsible and you would
have no chance of escape Marcus
would finally have the wall he talked
about the wall he always wanted no I
watched you open fire in a room full of
unarmed Starfleet officers you killed
them in cold blood
I took my crew from the you or a
murderer used my friends to control me I
tried to smuggle them to safety by
concealing them in the very weapons I
had designed but I was discovered I had
no choice but to escape alone when I did
I had every reason to suspect that
Marcus has killed every single one of
the people I hold most dear
[Music]
so I responded in kind my crew is my
family Kirk there anything you would not
do for your family proximity other sir
there's a human war pending right Lorne
cleanups at war okay we both I don't
think so
it's not coming at us from Kronos
[Music]
there's certain obviously recurring
things that you say but also that that
interviewers or profilers would say and
one of the things in terms of a
complimentary adjectives they're sort of
a sense that you're timeless there's
something about you you could have just
as easily been dropped into a movie with
Trevor Howard or you know Peter O'Toole
or somebody as as you are today and
blessing of having a weird face SSS
somewhere between an otter and something
that people find vaguely attractive just
an otter which is vaguely attractive
yeah it's I mean I you know on these
haughty list so I just had to go right
doesn't make any sense because I was no
and in that thousand patatas face when I
started out so I know I know a lot of
it's projection which is which is kind
of flattering about the work I suppose
but what I'm saying all that for is you
know I started on went yeah no you know
I'm not I'm not a typical beauty so
basically I've got a long neck long face
that's usually period that you see some
kind of inbreeding with it so I'll run
with that I wear some high collars and
got on the horse or two and the fine
with that but not all the time not
overnight all that sometimes I'll just
get a color the 21st century drama China
now as you'll notice I didn't show up so
ya know it's I kind of the otherworldly
I mean I had a great great English
teacher called Martin Cyril Oscar you
remember him and he said it's weird you
remind me of William Blake about what
the hallucinating visionary poets of the
Romantic era yeah we know you should see
you're quite an old soul and I kind of
like that and that a kind of an old soul
did some and say what I then not a new
soul and old soul old smelly
and I kind of I kind of ran with that
because I was fortunate enough to grow
up in England and you're surrounded by
your heritage then it's a very deep very
long very kind of old weary coming up my
heritage but like the Heritage at the
land and the culture and I went to
school where there were buildings that
were 400 years old and those were the
new ones you know I mean it was kind of
inspiring and it meant that whatever I
was doing in my context in my time I
could always see what the past had
evolved into and realize that we're not
all that far away from that we really
are and we you know it's important to be
able to recognize it and to be able to
honor it and and learn from it as well
you've got incredible fan base your work
in Sherlock yeah and we're going to
start off the open seat of an even
bigger one yeah it is intimidate you to
work in a film franchise with such rich
history high expectations and affable
fanbase for the good question
yes and no but on you know basically the
first film JJ's first outing with Star
Trek 2009 made me realized that the
franchise was in very safe hands and
that to be honest he's such an
extraordinary filmmaking human being if
I was pleasing his idea of what he
wanted my character to be within our
version of the track track them then
that was the only concern or
preoccupation I had to have with
expectations because otherwise that way
madness lies you're never going to be
everyone's meet someone's going to be
throwing up in the corner going as guys
and permadeath and that's fine little
that that's what the worlds that but and
you know I I'm very aware of course of
how possessive and rightfully so tricky
though you know there's a there's a huge
deal respect to happen because it's not
just a name for a group of fans it's
actually about a level of knowledge and
understanding of the subject matter but
it's a strange thing because actually
that takes ownership of what it is which
originally was a creative process and
proceeded by the mass audience and now
the audience is sort of taken control of
it so does go down bad without those
knowledge which are completely passive
and would love to you know the most my
time and a half done sense to the film
so yeah I think I was my fears which
were rightfully there obviously because
of that kind of presence and credibly
benevolent I mean however vocal they may
be about what they like or don't like
this their opinions they're not they're
not going to kill me it's just excited
that there's normal human beings you
just have a real enjoyment of quite a
quite exceptionally rich and you know
materially rich genre and and and and
cult that is something I want to see how
many imitations you can do put 60
seconds on the clock the imitation game
under the Cumberbatch strong Malkovich
well I don't know Alan Redmond Jones it
carried Sean Connery I said earlier film
I think it'd be a phenomenal idea I'm
very excited to see what young benedict
both Jack Nicholson why can we all see
the imitation game Tom Hiddleston yeah
yeah I think you've got to go and see
the imitation game that's going to grow
in Walsall it's kind of interesting
I don't where it's like a glove Michael
Caine I want to see the imitation bag
don't you
Christopher Walken I want to see this
done jamaican or something
15 seconds left wait can you do Bane I
would perceive you curse you Jerry
McConaughey can you do Taylor Swift um I
want to see the airmen creation janelda
the volca progress I have why yeah you
see this film I want to see this film
this shows me off my ass
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because today Tripathy
asked me to if there's someone you like
better profile in their future top ten
please check out the link down in the
description below and you can cast your
vote on who we should do next I also
want to give a quick shout out to Devon
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting it
on Instagram with all those other books
that you have when you're to read list
hopefully you'll put your one word at
the front of that to read list and let
me know what you think about it I hope
it has a big impact and again thank you
for the support thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
[Music]
is there ever any pressure because they
magic the bird the budget on this film
is not small do you ever mess up and
you're like I've been bitten about and I
send it on you you have to treat it like
you have to treat it like most other
jobs you really do otherwise yeah they
would get you very much so you just have
to you're facilitated all the way as
well so for me anyway I find that a real
privilege what makes me such a big fan
of yours is the fact that you seem to
completely disappear in the roads in the
characters you play no matter I can
share those allah julian assange
whatever you play we don't see you
anymore thank you is it something you
would say that one could learn that's
something I don't know don't want to say
a god-given gift or something which you
just have to have oh I think you can no
I think you could definitely learn that
I mean some of you you start to have to
feel but even that sort of intuitional
emotional kind of feeling you can you
can learn that by practice I think you
know when something is working you know
the rest of it you know absolutely I'd
never say that this was some kind of
exclusive gift for bit I think Anil is
realizing that I do believe everyone has
a painter or a drawer and the more
musician as well as plumbing is I mean
all of us role play all of us sort of
disappear to a varying degree in
different forms of our lives you know
whether it's a private or public face
that we have and yeah I think that makes
us all capable thing that just I don't
think it's the exclusive preserve of
those of us lucky enough to call it
living you know it's there like pressure
when you're doing a superhero and and
such a love superhero and do like an
immediate yes or do you like call anyone
and do do you ask that your friends and
family like can I be well I completely
because and I know people that know this
world and also this particular character
far better than me said yes you can and
it's a fantastic character yeah you'd
you should relish it because as loads of
challenges that you'll enjoy within the
kind of story and especially is an
origin story and also scott derrickson
the direct and Kevin Feige the popper in
a real sorcerer supreme of Marvel
Studios he they do the heavy lifting
when it comes to what that world is
about yeah Narva Cinematic Universe and
there's nothing that I know about the
comics there's nothing that they haven't
seen as well so the first people to get
bored as well as to reference what
should be then right and be nice
I can let them guide me again